mon nom est max ils actionnent
quand vous regarderez ceci
je serai mort
bonjour max veuillez maintenant évaluer
votre bien-être physique ce n'est pas
une bonne nouvelle
votre tumeur a considérablement grossi
vous m'écoutez
[Musique]
et un problème
j'aimerais qu'on soit toujours juste toi
et moi
[Musique]
ceci est un message de l'hôtel Aurora
une fois que vous avez signé notre
accord votre décision ne peut être ni
annulé ni reporter
ta vie bizarrement non tu vas bien non
vous avez choisi d'en terminer tout ce
qu'il nous reste à faire c'est de vous
offrir une fin digne je tenais à vous
souhaiter un excellent voyage
je voudrais réviser quelques aspects du
plan
vous savez parfois je me sens un peu
perdue j'ai besoin de parler que une
dernière fois
je serai rien du tout ça
tu vas y aller laisse-moi t'accompagner
[Musique]
tu veux rentrer à la maison